يتفق الكثيرون على أن وجود مداعبة من جانبنا
يجعل أيامنا أفضل وبالنسبة لبعض
الفرسان أيضًا ، حيث ينام الزيتون في
السرير معنا كل
ليلة بصراحة فوقي حيث
ينام أرشي ينام أرشي في السرير مع
زوجي وأنا لا أوافقه على
ذلك.  تفضل النوم معنا فقط
لكنها محببة جيدة أشعر
بالتأكيد براحة أكبر عندما يكون
هناك وكذلك الدكتور ليندسي ميركل في
مدرسة بيطرية بجامعة مينيسوتا ، لذا
كم عدد الكلاب التي تنام في سريرك في
سريرنا من أجل الشيواوا وواحد صغير من
الكلاب الألمانية  إذن ، خمسة كلاب في سرير واحد ، خمسة
كلاب ، شخصان اثنان ، نعم ، أنا وزوجي ،
لذلك قد لا تتفاجأ
إذا سمحنا لكلابنا بالنوم معنا ، أه
نعطي كل ما نفهمه
عن الفوائد التي يمكن أن نستفيدها
من نوم الحيوانات في سريرنا
معنا ، أعتقد أن جعلهم ينامون
معنا فكرة رائعة حتى يمكن أن يهدئ
كلانا عندما ننام معًا ،
ويبدو أنه يفرز
الهرمونات المفيدة التي نحتاجها للتوتر.
ليف وأنت تعلم أن الشعور بالرضا تجاه
أنفسنا ، فإن الدوبامين والأوكسيتوسين
أجرت Mayo Clinic بعض الأبحاث أيضًا ، وهي
دراسة تتبع النوم ، وهي تتبع كلبًا ينام في
غرفة النوم وهم بشر ،
وتقول الدراسة إن وجود الكلب في السرير يمكن أن
يعطل النوم ولكن وجود الكلب  على
الأرض بجانب السرير ليس كذلك ولكن طالما
أنك لا تعاني من الحساسية وليس
لديهم طفيليات ، تقول الدكتورة ميركل إنه لا بأس
من الذهاب إلى كل شيء يبدو أن الدليل هو
أن وجودهم في
سريرك هو في الواقع  مفيد
لكليكما ، أعتقد أن الكثير من
مشاهدينا سيحبونه تمامًا ، أنا متأكد
من أنه من المفترض أن يكون مجرد
تهدئة للقلق ، لم أكن أعرف ذلك ، لذا فأنت
لا تفعل أشياء سيئة لا إنه مهدئ
هناك الدوبامين ، سأضطر في الواقع
إلى مشاركة ذلك مع زوجي الآن
لدي حقيقة فعلية لإقناعه
بأننا نفعل الشيء الصحيح ، فنحن نتعامل
مع بعضنا البعض.